welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and shongshi in the legend of the
10 rings biggest scene stealer was wong
not only portaling into the indian post
credit scene to snatch some free booze
but running the weirdest side hustle
with abomination as cage fighters even
in a movie with interdimensional soul
suckers who show up from who the hell
knows where this is what has me the most
curious ooh give me more of that wrong
stuff how did these two meet where did
they go back to why has an abomination
depowered into human form like bruce
banner did but rather evolved into this
alternate abomination who wears pants i
thought it was okay to go pantsless in
2021 i was promised
now you gotta check out the new shengchi
inspired great protector shirt at new
rockstarsmerch.com this is the eighth
design and the latest obsession line of
collectible shirts the best way can
support us here at new rockstars it's an
amazing design inspired by classic
chinese art and the climactic battle
from the movie this is a limited edition
so grab yours now before they're gone at
newrockstarsmerch.com so wong and
abomination appear about halfway through
the shanghai film at the golden daggers
club along with a hodgepodge of
interesting warriors from the mcu
including a former black widow from the
black widow film and an extremist
soldier from iron man 3 but abomination
and wong were the prized match
abomination was last seen ko'd in harlem
by the edward norton version of hulk in
the 2008 film emil blonsky was a deadly
commando who signed up for thaddeus
ross's human enhancement serum which
ross got from a cryo container dating
all the way back to dr erskine and
howard stark's super soldier experiments
which gave blonsky super strength and
agility and then he took another serum
with banner's blood transforming him
into abomination but since his defeat
he's been locked away somewhere
mentioned only by agent coulson in a
season one episode of agents of shield
if anyone gets hurt i'll reassign you to
barrow alaska and you'll spend the rest
of your years pulling the night shift
guarding blonsky's cryo cell suggesting
that emil blonsky has just been frozen
in some cryo cell in alaska but now he
is sparring with wong in macau china
with a new design a greener color tone
and fins in wearing pants when asked
about these changes the director daniel
dustin [ __ ] said cryptically i can't
really say anything about abomination
laughs i think abomination got a bit of
an upgrade or we might call it an
evolution going through time if the
director just wanted to spruce up
abomination to look more comic accurate
than the 2008 film just say so but i
can't really say anything suggests that
this cameo was probably inserted in the
movie by marvel studios an abomination's
appearance upgrade was decided on by the
studio's design team and it really
speaks to the overall randomness of
abominations showing up in this film
just to leave minutes later it's clear
marvel studios just wanted a high
profile reminder of abominations
existence in the mcu ahead of his
confirmed return in the disney plus
series she-hulk sometime next year and
between that and wong's return in
spider-man no way home there's likely to
be some answer that explains exactly how
wong and abomination cross paths in one
of these upcoming properties that the
shengqi team cannot speak to directly
but we were given a few clues to how
wong an abomination could have met one
is the fact that wong and abomination
are not bitter rivals but actually
partners who apparently pre-plan all of
their hits because afterward wong snaps
at blonsky for actually hitting him
which is why wong ko'd him using a
portal to knock himself out but i don't
think this was a monetary hustle for
either one of them to profit from
placing bets on the winner because they
are having this conversation in
zhaling's office rather i just think
wong and abomination agreed to
participate as a stunt to draw a crowd
there's also the fact that wong calls
abomination a meal showing that he
recognizes the human soul inside this
monstrous body and finally and perhaps
most importantly when they depart on the
other side of wong's portal is some kind
of containment cell probably where
abomination is kept now in my breakdown
i pointed out that the background does
look a lot like the raft the ocean-based
prison where thaddeus ross tried to
detain half of the avengers in civil war
and where zemo was detained at the end
of the falcon winter soldier which means
abomination could be involved with
whatever thunderbolts initiative that
ross might be cooking up with val
alongside u.s agent john walker and
elena bulova ross might allow
abomination to participate in this match
as part of a pr campaign to paint him as
a beloved warrior celebrity or a feared
don't mess with us flex to the badass
former black widows extremist soldiers
and 10 rings warriors of the world
similar to the pr campaign that val
apparently has in mind for john walker's
u.s agent with that nice new suit but my
problem with this is why would wong join
a shadowy government initiative when he
is still working with the real avengers
is wang a spy is he a scroll is ima
vista no no and no not that kind of
video that'll be in the dry weeks of
october when everyone in our videos will
be trick-or-treating as skrulls or
devils now ottoman north america brings
seasonal activities apple picking
breaking leaves and adults screaming
about fantasy football this video is
brought to you by draftkings the leader
in daily fantasy sports draftkings is
putting you in the center of the action
with a shot at millions of dollars in
prizes every week of the football
regular season in her football daily
fantasy contests all season long with
millions of prizes get in on the action
now by downloading draftkings new users
can use promo code new rockstars during
sign up and get a shot at millions of
dollars in prizes with your first
deposit it's easy to play just draft
nine players that fit under the game's
salary cap and then rack up fantasy
points for touchdowns yards field goals
and so much more i've drafted my week
one team i started with pat mahomes the
quarterback for kansas city because i
know he's great and i enjoy his
commercial work and then as a good
florida boy i made sure to draft at
least one former florida gator and then
one buffalo bill in honor of tom
bechtold and a bunch of other players i
think will have good games it's fun so
get in on the action by clicking the
link in the description to download
draftkings and then use promo code new
rockstars during sign up and get a shot
at millions of dollars in prizes with
your first deposit but i do think wong's
involvement is connected to that mystery
of bruce banner appearing back in human
form in the post-credits scene because
after bruce fused his brain with his
brawn after 18 months in the gamma lab
that seemed to be a permanent state and
we know shangji is after that because
bruce now wears a sling from the injury
he got from snapping everyone back in
in-game the director's description of
abomination's new look as an evolution
going through time this might just be me
but it does remind me of that quantum
scene and end game when banner
accidentally sent scott lang through
time or really time through scott
transforming scott into older and
younger versions of himself i i see this
as an absolute win i have speculated
before how banner totally stumbled upon
an immortality machine that would allow
himself to de-age himself back into his
human form if he wanted to and now maybe
bruce banner in a post-flip society
where things have gone back to normal
might not want to shop at the big and
tall store anymore and try to use this
to transition back into his human form
but unable to do his arm injury because
the infinity stones are like an absolute
point that can't be undone but first
decides to experiment on the one other
person he knows about to undergo this
kind of transformation emil blonsky but
chaotic quantum entanglement involves
blonsky into this new form so banner
seeks the sorcerer's help and they use
that soul detachment trick in order to
revert banner to his human form and now
seeing the need for some hulk style
warrior in the avengers decide to help
shape abomination into a hero before
ross's dark initiative can recruit him i
know that sounds like a lot of steps
really the simplest answer might be the
tva and variant logic as simple as that
is just because variants from all
strength universes are known to take
different forms just like this like loki
versus sylvie so abomination 2008 versus
abomination in chiang chi could be
explained away as they're just variants
of each other and that could be what the
director was hinting at by evolution
through time i've always suspected that
marvel sorcerers could be connected to
the tva into kang because he who remains
echoes their timeline logic the sacred
timeline visuals are the same and we did
see a sanctum sanctorum appearing in the
tva's void so perhaps this green or
thinned abomination is a variant from
another universe who spilled into this
universe as a result of the sacred
timeline fracturing the way it did in
loki and now wong has befriended this
guy as a sparring partner that could
actually explain the version of the
sanctum sanctorum in strange and wong
that we see in spider-man no way home
why is the sanctum frozen well that ice
might be to keep abominations cryofreeze
cold enough and now wong is warning
strange not to screw up the multiverse
even further but strange is like look we
already got variant blonskies and
variant j jonah jameson's this is gonna
get worse with or without us wong so
let's meddle and collect as many alt
universe villains as we can and store
them under our supervision i get that
wong and abomination being connected to
thunderbolts is probably a simpler
explanation for most people but look
this is the marvel cinematic multiverse
folks nothing simple anymore comment
with your theory for wong and
abominations meet cute you can follow me
on instagram and twitter at eavos follow
and subscribe to new rockstars thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you